cannes de patrick lecocq france roche et
leurs invités du cinéma italien
oui vittorio gassman le disait qu'il n'y
avait pas qu'en italie où il y avait des
problèmes tant à voir un exemple la
france sache si nous parlions cinéma
alors un palais baroques une terrasse
pas tout à fait celle où nous sommes
aujourd'hui une terrasse qui est
beaucoup plus belle et un club d'anciens
combattants mais leur guerre eux ils
n'ont pas fait sur le front de l'est
l'ouest ils l'ont fait sur le front de
l'intelligentsia
il ya là un scénariste un producteur il
ya là un journaliste un romancier et
puis un député bien sûr l'italie ou
l'espagne
leur problème c'est qu'ils ont
finalement tous atteint la cinquantaine
et ils savent pas très bien où vivent
tellement qu'ils aient atteint la
cinquantaine mais qu'il est atteint dans
l'état où ils sont car en fait ce film
c'est en 2h45 les frustrés au masculin
et à l'italienne et sur cette terrasse
aux députés partagent les canapés et les
propos aigres doux et acerbe avec un
certain nombre de ses confrères qui sont
dans le même triste état heureusement
les femmes elles sont en meilleur état
comme on le verra avec stefania
sandrelli tendu gassmann comme député
député du parti communiste
j'espère qu'on va le retrouver tous les
cas un petit problème semble-t-il de
liaison avec ma maladie est nécessaire
bonjour la soupe à la grimace quand aux
communistes
non les capitaux malgré deux journaux
les volets notamment les commerçants
vrai lit dans ce film vous êtes très
agressive et en italie les femmes sont
aussi polémique avec les hommes mais je
suis agressif seulement au début
pierre frey je me calme par les montées
rapides à leiria la conférence de presse
vous avez dit que les femmes en italie
n'ont pas de grands rôles dans la vie je
disais cinéma
donc il n'y a pas de de gaulle
quand ils arrivent d'un plan numérique
et vous pensez que ça vient des metteurs
en scène italien né cette année la vie
la tradition c'est la tradition
italienne
oui mais ça bouge ça change j'aime
beaucoup
et tandis que la députée communiste dans
les salons notre bourgeoisie italienne
c'est de la provocation
non pourquoi sa commune ce sont des
entraîneurs bam qui boit et le swell
rencontre les amis sont pas des bêtes
très étrange qui font aujourd'hui mon
astique austère c'est pas vrai dont
milan qu'en france on voit mal un député
du parti communiste aller dîner toutes
les semaines tous les mois mais auch ou
aimer c'est justement pour ça que je
crois que les parties s'étaient beaucoup
de freins touristes français et dans le
parti comme si de rien il y a je pars
dire une grande liberté
quelle liberté dans les parties peut
être et qui a mené à la conclusion comme
nous avons des partis comme ça avec
beaucoup de courant ont du courant mais
ça arrive pas dans le parti communiste
qui avait fusionné me compact fusionner
sur les unit mais au delà il y à un
grand jeu de change d'idée même
contraire les à l'autre d'en souffrir il
ya un député communiste très communiste
très sincères et rester au paris alors
que certains de ses amis le quittait
pour aller plus d'un marxisme jeu disons
plus après les faits de l'ombre et tout
ça mais maintenant il demande à son
parti un jour nous opérations majeures
débat débat collectif public même des
sentiments privées qui doivent être
collectives et les problèmes personnels
et ce mal il était de mesure des
problèmes collectifs et l'eau c'est pour
ça qu'il faudrait en parler une autre
question qu'il pose à son parti c'est de
résoudre au de se prononcer sur que son
quelles doivent être les rapports entre
le parti et les intellectuels qui est en
question qui a posé toliary lie à 20 ans
avec victorine qui était un écrivain
italien très connue en italie et je
passe pas en france et il y avait ce
débat c'est l'intellectuel doit être
tout à fait d'être un communiste libre
de son parti et suivre semences et idées
ou bien de de corriger ses idées et de
faire atterrir ses idées à ça à sa foi
politique et ce débat qu'est un grand
débat a pas eu une collection n'a pas de
tradition
on n'a pas fait beaucoup pas fait assez
alors cessé ses députés demandent à son
parti de parler de ça de continuer à
parler de ça et c'est une des questions
que l'on pose aujourd'hui à notre parti
et qui est un parti communiste mais un
parti de questions qui se posent
beaucoup de questions que vous ne
regardez pas vous avez vous avez fait
votre choix et de l'aspect individuel
l'emportent sur l'aspect collectif où
l'individualisme l'emportent sur le
collectivisme si je peux dire pour vous
et c'est le choix déjà non non je crois
que non et je crois que les mutualistes
doivent y brille car l'important doit
être au centre de l'attention mais il
doit à cool coli mais il doit à
s'identifier avec les problèmes
cognitifs c'est ça qui dans quelle
mesure on on a déjà commencé à faire
plus de dégâts sans doute partagé
l'opinion de détresse que je peux dire
d'un point de vue personnel que le le le
moment que j'aime le plus généralement
c'est quand je m'adresse l'écrit ci au
congrès et je pose une question qui est
encore plus large c'est à dire la
possibilité du bonheur et la
signification du bonheur parce qu'après
tout
les partis de gauche pas seulement le
parti communiste mais le mail à gauche
en général est fondée sur un principe de
réalisme de vision réaliste de la vie et
je pense que le bonheur soit quelque
chose qui ne doivent pas rester abstrait
mais doit se réaliser cinq armées je
suis très d'accord là j'ai tenté de
mettre le plus de ma conviction
personnelle et est ce que le bonheur
peut être codifiée par un parti
politique ou pas mal dans son dos par
dubaï vers le mensonge s'est fait qu'un
grand tel c'est une grande gageure
nature et manquent pas donner des
formules rigide ça s'adapte au temps a
pas pas à la mode mais à la passe et les
temps et des situations peut pas
généraliser il faut il faut c'est un
thème long qui va durer longtemps mais
certainement c'est un thème vivent
aujourd'hui en italie et j'espère
ailleurs dans le film que si les députés
communistes peuvent très facilement
aller prendre des petits sandwichs dans
des très belles maisons
il est plutôt mal vu qu'ils souhaitent
adultère et que étant marié avec une
dame qui les a suivis
dans toute leur carrière politique il
rencontre une jeune dame dans des
studios et l'armée l'édicule la famille
par exemple c'est une institution c'est
une autre réalité très fortes font des
jeux ses militants la vérité
kleinostheim contre israël ou militants
si les portes et non pas avec les
limites langoustines et event indiqué
que quelques concessions
ajoutez une inspection sur le cahier que
les dépositions et l'egypte
christo
messi
estime à des sommets en compte au titre
avec le concept ne le pense au pew
cosy mario côté humiliante en huitièmes
à la noche del sol et au poulet non
non c'est une ville riche il a une
famille
oui
malchance
ciao te dire
l'espèce est confrontée l'économie
à chier
le taux de vichy
omer
toi
presque la wii dans la sainte qui suivit
le député demande un congrès il imagine
de demander si est possible d'être
même si sa probable que créent les mâles
d'autres persos et c'est une question à
mon avis très important qu'elle sait pas
une question personnelle et qu'elle ses
députés et c'est justement ça qui
demande et quelque chose sur le bonheur
général sur le bonheur de tout le monde
et c'est ce qu'il qu'il souhaite il peut
pas avoir la réponse il n'ya pas ce que
vous avez dit madame que le parti un pas
qu'il aille
une autre femme le parti ils s'en
foutent un peu de ces questions est sûre
ça ils demandent pas de réponse il veut
il repose sur le bonheur sociale
collective
et oui justement il n'y a pas de réponse
le parti répons packard et ce sont des
questions
un acte mais il n'y a pas encore de
réponse nous voyons autour de nous et le
mot n'est pas tellement eu et il y a
seulement quelqu'un qui est l'heureux
est sur les épaules des autres c'est ça
qui est pas juste assure avi et alors
c'est ça qu'est le film peut pas
répondre à ça pose souvent des questions
c'est un film de questions pas de
réponse les réponses ont plutôt quand on
est spectateur et qu'on regarde donc la
terrasse figure 240 que nous verrons je
crois à partir de septembre soit jusqu'à
la fin septembre dans les écrans sur les
écrans français
alors si on parlait un peu de la crise
du cinéma puisque vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure que vous même et on est
ce que là vous en avait parlé en disant
que la clé du cinéma finalement c'était
un peu la crise de votre crise et de la
crise des gens qui ont 50 ans le cinéma
italien
la crise du cinéma italien et que cinéma
italien perdu 30 % de sa clientèle
alors ça c'est déjà quelque chose de
très peu souvent on la met commun comme
effet je pense que
soit presque une cause la zone effect et
le cinéma italien et je souffre de sa
démarche de renouvellement et nous
sommes toujours là toujours le même et
j'aimerais faire des films avec des
jeunes acteurs
victor est amené à faire des films avec
un jeune metteur en scène il y a pas
tellement de jeunes étrangers il ya pas
terme à date heure et c'est pas un cas
c'est pas qu'il n'existe pas je pense
qu'il existe qui sont là mais les
structures et nous mêmes nous avons pas
fait tout ce que nous devions nous
voulions
pour susciter ces nouvelles forces et
donc donc je pense que la faute est même
encore un peu à nous à nos auteurs à la
critique italien et qui est tout à fait
différent de la critique française et la
critique et italienne est de très peu le
public à comprendre la critique se
parlent ils parlent entre eux et ils
créent quelques fois un peu de méfiance
de république vers le cinéma on a en
parlé avant avec être ça dépend si on
peut tenter une généralisation ça défend
d'un fait très très curieuse je crois
personnellement que pas seulement les
critiques mais les français en général
aiment le cinéma plus que les italiens
je vois dans l'attitude des critiques
français par exemple même quand ils ne
sont pas d'accord
un amour très clair très viscéral très
directe pour pour le cinéma dit chez
nous est plus rare ça existe aussi mais
dans de très rares exemples et richard
déficit français par exemple n'ont pas
aimé des films qui ont eu un énorme
succès et ça c'est parfaitement légitime
non c'est un choix et c'est une
dialectique encore mais à la base il y à
il ya l'amour pour un pour la trois
choses
certains quand on lit les critiques
italiennes on a l'impression que les
critiques italiens pour ces sortes de
devoir lutter mais qui est il faut deux
essais la critique
et mieux littéraire main et murs
critiquement mais s'occupe pas de ce que
doit être la vie le devoir d'un critique
ses deux métiers avec le public les
idées d'un film il se troue pas comme ça
mais du coup c'est un prince il ya une
crise de public geste ruines aux mains
dans le chai moniteur
faudrait travailler que jeune metteur en
scène et vous avez un jeune homme étant
sa naturalisation de films que vous
massacrez littéralement dans votre film
oui car il n'est pas un jeu mais il est
même si la vente en car il veut
seulement inité quelqu'un il a rien à
dire il est petit
bovo le 2
deux séquences une idée d autres maîtres
anciens et je la préfère à ferrer qui a
fait des choses il ya tout beaucoup de
pilotes qui limite qui font des films
très mauvaise semaine pour pas pour ma
part c'est pas dégeu mettra ses fils en
réalité ils entourent le 2 2 le premier
et le dernier à la fois partout sinon
j'espère chez nous d'ailleurs on nomme
simon mizrahi qui est acceptable et
qu'on verra un peu moment le festival de
cannes et la télévision sont également
traitées sur cette télévision qu'elle
est disponible et premio nom avait selon
lui ils n'ont et cannes à chantilly
bensalah et par la commissaire acquis si
ready steady chesneau la production
demande était mal fait sur lost s
organisent en appel à contrer contre
communications critiques que sa taille
tout le monde va dans la rue dit cela va
vous coûter 6 mo misrahi c'est
socialement comme ça alors oui je crois
moi j'ai ainsi j'ai eu l'occasion
d'assister un certain nombre de deux
réunions où l'on voyait un peu des gens
des gens de cinéma de toutes sortes qui
se crêpaient le chignon de façon
assez curieuse est assez sympathique
c'est les moeurs du cinéma italien les
gens les gens quand même occasion de
rencontrer dans d'antan des terrasses
comme celle que vous présenterez
torrestrella sont une forme folle assez
curieuse et des scènes comme celle là
j'ai l'occasion d'y assister
mais vous simon qui est le trait d'union
entre cinéma français cinéma italien et
se connaissaient vous êtes le français
qui connaît mieux les réalisateurs
italiens et comment pouvez vous
expliquer tous les cinémas italiens
semblent plus aimé en france qu'en
italie
c'est pas que le cinéma italien dans son
ensemble soit plus aimé en france en
italie
je crois qu'il ya toute une frange de
cinéastes italiens qui ne sont pas
qu'ils n'ont jamais été en tout cas pas
là jusqu'à ce jour
respectées estimé et et découvert comme
il le fallait et en tout cas estimés à
leur juste valeur les up
je parle des cinéastes qui ont oeuvré
dans un jean bien précis que le genre de
la comédie italienne
et ça c'était préjugés qui existent
depuis depuis toujours depuis depuis pau
d'aucune manière
ce préjugé féroce contre la comédie et
les critiques italiens ont toujours eu
un préjugé très nette un mépris très
affichée très affirmée contre la comédie
italienne puis j'ai l'avant cet italien
de u2 de la culture officielle italienne
qui a toujours une certaine soupçons
le tout ce qui est amusant et est vital
ce parallèle cuvée de l'auteur
beaucoup plus honteux beaucoup de fin de
vie en france à paris en france on a au
contraire réussi parce que les films
étaient était magnifique et que les gens
comme disait vittorio en france que ce
soit le public ou les critiques qui ont
une véritable passion en amour du cinéma
ont sans préjuger découvert ces films et
les ont estimés alors juste valeur et
soudain on a découvert un cinéma en
france qui est au moins aussi riche que
les cinémas officielle des metteurs en
scène des officiels que ces prix que ces
crises exit a bien aimé poneys et dès
lors certains auteurs dont ettore scola
son sont estimées comme il le mérite
je veux dire que j'en suis moins une
question je voulais poser et ouest doit
se classer savoir comment il avait fait
parce que réunir sur une même affiche
tognazzi vittorio gassman marcello
mastroianni reggiani serge gianni
français lui jean louis trintignant
stéphanie ce les avoir tous au même
moment à la même heure à choisir sur un
plateau ça ne doit pas être très facile
de travailler avec ces monstres sacrés
du cinéma quand même à nous à on n'a pas
tellement et non il faudrait
et rinko non mais tu n'as pas le
problème a dit stéphanie c'est vrai il y
avait il y avait sur le plateau et dans
la préparation du film
ils ont une atmosphère amicale c'était
une aventure une gageure difficile à
laquelle hommes
on aimait de participer à la session
comprend pas c est ce que vous autres
acteurs est rentré dans cette espèce de
sentiment au de punitif que les taux
restent là semble avoir une dent la
terrasse est vraiment c'est un film où
vous êtes
c'est la faute à la forme et nous ne
voulons pas de risque nous acteurs nous
nous cachons dans un personnage nous
avons toujours pénalisées hyper mal ont
disposé à changer tous deux coups et
faire le contraire nous sommes nous
sommes immortel dans ce sens là soit de
jossot son hub un blé sable vous avez
quand même une partie vous même dans les
dialogues ou dans la manière dont vous
de jouer
hassan devant le congrès du parti
communiste incontestablement on n'a pas
l'impression qu'il ya un texte qui est
écrit on a l'impression que c'est c'est
vittorio gassman lui-même qui ont selon
elle moi je suis socialiste je suis pas
communiste difficultés à le dire alors
il y à il ya quelques quelques
contradictions aussi des nuances ou même
essentiel mais mais ça c'est le jeu de
l'acteur s'est lancée la base et je dois
dire que la la directive fondamentale du
film
mais trouver assez bien d'accord surtout
j'ai aimé la l'ambiguïté je pense que le
mérite principal des traits du film
c'est de ne pas avoir établi une ligne
manichéiste ou de l'illusion de donner
des formules permanente
il ya comme un secteur qui fait rien
c'est les hommes c'est le murray et
femmes seulement si on sait pas
tellement tellement n'est et une
certaine sympathie pour les familles une
ré cognition du fait qu'elles sont plus
plus plus forte plus physiquement folk
et doivent l'être parce qu'elles ont des
fonctions très importante maintenant et
mon espoir mon souhait c'est seulement
qu'elles ne payent par l'acquisition de
pouvoir avec trop de pertes sur le plan
du mollet
ces familles mais une
d'accord avec les beatles parce que
quand on exerce
a besoin que de la femme fort depuis de
sa maman de salle du solier vis de sa
femme de
les sa copine toujours elle a toujours
besoin de la femme fort il faut que ces
nuits dans la tête face je crois que
nous allons bientôt nous séparent et
nous allons laisser vite je crois que
vous allez quitter très rapidement fait
si nous partons aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il est juste pour la
présentation de votre film ça veut dire
que les autres ne vous intéresse pas ou
plus non non j'aimerais bien rester mais
j'ai des choses il faut que l'air ou
bouge encore ce festival qui est le film
que vous alliez me voir si j'étais
restée moi je veux voir décidément le
film de kurosawa formation ça
m'intéresse beaucoup et je fais les
mines j'ai déjà vu bon le verrons je
crois je dis je me trompe
la lundi prochain très beau film voilà
de toute façon je pense que c'est en
discuter a dit non non c'est un discours
long
elle est plus long concert merci les
gars sont à venir s'y est collé cela
merci stéphane il est devenu un exercice
non israël et c'était notre premier
rendez vous à cannes où nous retrouvons
maintenant
mercredi nous parlerons france du
western tout une émission sur le western
c'est un sujet qui effectivement est à
l'occasion de ce festival le d'actualité
voilà moi j'ai rendez vous de 18h30
et tandis que là bas il ne pourra pas
être là mais on regardera ce mois là
18h30
journal noël mamère c'est la vie et nous
on se retrouve à paris pour nouvelle
antenne 2010 demain à 12h45 brûlis